finally leaders of germany's main
parties have agreed on a coalition pact
the deal ends two months of wrangling
spd leader sigma gabriel
chancellor angela merkel and christian
social union leader host zhoufer
were all smiles at a signing ceremony
and this is what the deal looks like a
manifesto for germany's future
after that leaders left the ceremony for
a press conference
there angela merkel outlined her new
government's priorities
for this accord is in the spirit of a
grand coalition
we're aiming to solve germany's big
challenges
i think that those challenges can be
grouped into three categories
one solid finances two assuring
prosperity and three
social security
the deal is done but spd leader sigma
gabriel now has to secure a yes vote
from his party's rank and file
many are opposed so gabriel is trying to
allay concerns
a lot of places this coalition deal
proves that politics isn't a lofty
pursuit
something that's decided in parliament
or the chancellor's office politics is
about people's lives
about their concerns hopes and
opportunities
the leaders agreed on a deal early on
wednesday morning
many germans wonder why it took them so
long to agree
if the majority in germany thinks we
should have a grand coalition
then it could have all gone a bit faster
it's about time that we got an effective
government again
it took long enough i think in the long
run a grant coalition is not going to be
good for one of the two partners
in this case the spd that is if the spd
rank and file agree to the deal
the results of a party ballot are
expected mid-december
if they approve germany will get its
third-ever grand coalition government